Right now, what is most important is to line up Mount Everest.
Now,
line up many picks, do them in India, do them outside,
but until you climb Everest,
until you understand the level of Everest
[Music].  ]
I understood that it will cost a
lot of money but my
struggle is more, no, I looked at it in a different way,
why is she doing this,
what will she get by going out, she is a girl,
stay within limits, she has faced
problems in the life of a human being.  That's why
she has come either to improve or to get shattered
[Music]
Information from many people Kari's daughter
wants to go to Mount Everest, I don't know
what to do
[Music] [
Music] We have to
reach till now and hoist the Indian tricolor,
go there  I feel happy that I have
proved that you are no less than anyone
[Music]